je vous entend plus oui alors c'est
possible et on s'en rapproche un peu
parce que avec la station spatiale nous
avons cinq agences qui travaille sur la
station spatiale internationale
et on peut très bien regroupée ces cinq
agences spatiales sous l'égide d'un
centre coordinateur qui serait une
agence mondiale mais il faudrait bien
sûr y inclure les autres agences qui
sont importantes comme la chine et
l'inde du tourisme social c1 est une des
applications du futur donc le tourisme
social a commencé déjà et il va
s'accélérer dans les dix à vingt années
qui vont venir et je pense qu'il va
accélérer de plus en plus bien sûr mais
c'est pas la seule application
l'application obligations importantes
pour nous c'est quand même le tourisme
social dans les orbites basses mais
c'est surtout l'exploration pour que
nous puissions faire un travail
scientifique important sur des
différentes planètes comme la lune ou
mars
ou bien des tâches importantes qui
compte qu'ils sont là pour protéger la
terre comme par exemple intercepté un
astéroïde
il n'y a pas un pro militaire dans
l'espace mais il y a un droit juridique
qui est assez récent puisque aucun pays
ne vous laisse s'en occupe et donc le
luxembourg s'est porté volontaire pour
faire des universités du droit spatial
et ses lois spatiales doivent être
appliquées par tous les pays du monde
sinon il pourrait y avoir un en bas au
[Musique]
il est très important parce que nous
sommes dépendants de l'espace pour
plusieurs choses pour la localisation la
navigation comme gps donc celui qui
détient le gps donne le signal à son
pays ou à cette héritière pour qu'ils
puissent naviguer en toute sécurité
nous avons également des choses limites
comme par exemple les brouillages gps
qui peuvent amener les gens dans des
secteurs où ils ont pas vraiment envie
d'aller mais aussi tout ce qui est
communication de transmission de données
donc des données très importantes
puisque nous avons par internet
aujourd'hui est que ce internet nous
l'avons par des réseaux filaires
d'aujourd'hui cet internet et dans le
futur se fera par des réseaux
satellitaires de très haute donne et qui
vont couvrir toute la planète et ça
c'est vraiment un avantage par rapport à
ce que nous avions
[Musique]
alors c'est un cheval incroyable parce
que je me souviens que ce vol de
gagarine durée une orbite donc une heure
39 40 autour de la terre en augmenter
dans la durée pour faire une journée une
semaine quinze jours et on s'est rendu
compte rapidement tes des problèmes
qu'on avait dans les vols longs donc on
a on a réussi à augmenter cette durée
jusqu'à faire des vols de six mois un an
le record absolu est temps je crois 14
mois et donc en un contrôle de commande
comment l'être humain se comportent en
apesanteur qui sont des conditions
difficiles de dégradation de l'offre
dégradation des muscles confinement
psychologique et toutes ces données que
dans avait depuis 60 ans permettent
aujourd'hui de retourner sur la lune
de façon plus scientifique on va dire et
de préparer avec ses veaux lunaire le
vol qui rassure mars
alors moi je moi j'aime beaucoup le film
gravity bien que le scénario soit pas
réaliste mais j'aime beaucoup les images
de gravity il ya des erreurs bien sûr
dans ce film-là donc pour tout ce qui
est des images en orbite basse
j'aime beaucoup le film gravity pour
tout ce qui est résistance psychologique
j'aime bien le vote le film seul sur
mars le scénario est impossible encore
une fois parce que on n'abandonne jamais
un astronaute
même si les blessés même si les mots ont
leur amène avec nous mais là le fait de
vouloir survivre à tout prix représente
bien un peu le sentiment que nous avons
de toujours vouloir s'en sortir et de
faire le maximum pour sauver la mission
est resté en vie jusqu'au bout